these words of Thomas Jefferson author of the
Declaration of Independence third President of
the United States founder of the University of
Virginia have a special meaning for colleges
and universities today the appeal to force is
being answered by the youth of America fifteen
hundred colleges throughout the nation are being
converted to the war effort all branches of the
armed forces need the trained minds of youth in
consultation with faculty and advisory officers
students are guided to the specialized training
they need for world work virginia's dawn patrol
composed of voluntary students who are eager to
equip themselves for advanced military training
to follow this is the spirit of young men
today naval ROTC units throughout the country
train thousands of students Virginia cadets are
taught the mathematical problems of navigation
by experienced officers students learn military
phrases in aviation terms to wait understanding
at the many foreign fronts medical schools are
turning out doctors and nurses faster than ever
before today military medicine is required by all
medical students doctors in the making are signed
for active service months ahead of graduation
complete combat units are formed ready for the
call to duty abroad blood banks in College
Hospital supply valuable plasma to the many
BattleBots University facilities over the country
are being used by the Armed Forces in the Virginia
law school for the first time a class and military
government is held high ranking officers study for
future assignments to govern occupied territories
dollar General Dynamics Department supplying
many engineers to aviation plants well-equipped
laboratories give training to future designers
nearly 80,000 new fliers have already started
their careers at six hundred college airfields
over the nation this Civilian Pilot training
course is now one of wartime bases though small
these planes give the students the feel of flying
and they're also used by the army as observers to
direct ground traffic and gunfire Indiana's Purdue
University has seen from the air many heroes
of today received their preliminary instruction
that these college fields upon graduation college
flying classes often enter advanced training in
squadrons to fly together in combat taking the
effective teamwork of American athletes to the
dogfights in the air here secret experimental
work is sponsored by the government under the
guidance of aeronautical engineers it takes
36 men to keep each for motored bomber flying
ground school classes and colleges all over the
country teach students the fundamentals of plane
construction and the theory of flying the world's
largest and finest facilities for supplying
trained manpower our pledge to meet our immediate
and long-range warning machines and the brains
to direct these instruments of warfare win the
Wars of today these great mind power plants are
meeting the challenge the dual engineer students
get experienced with the tools that produce
war materials by actually making parts for
war machines practice is combined with theory in
this mechanical designing class and this ordnance
inspectors group sends men and women to the
plants that produce our guns tanks and machines
most Engineer students are already enlisted in
the Armed Forces this Signal Corps group works
with ultra-high frequencies for special training
in the operation of plane and submarine detectors
there are now about two hundred eighteen
thousand college students enrolled in the
Army ROTC courses who are enlisted in some branch
of the Armed Forces these Paducah deaths are part
of the largest carnage field artillery unit in
the country long hours of practice with fully
motorized equipment gives students the training
that makes them efficient at the Battlefront when
the full course is completed they are ready for
active duty as well-trained soldiers servicemen
with books now a common sight on the campus at
many colleges the Armed Forces of stationed band
to get specialized training these sailors compete
for higher ratings as electrician mates thousands
of college women now volunteer for courses that
train them for jobs vacated by men gone to war the
Duke coeds take advantage of engineering equipment
by learning how to operate communications offices
farm health is a problem that women will now
be called upon more than ever to solve these
college girls want to be ready for duty at the
homefront many women's colleges are awake to the
need of preparing for war work they are guarding
their courses to fit in the war program women are
needed in all branches of aviation technical
knowledge enables them to fill many jobs held
exclusively by men before the war ferry pilots
are needed and women can fill these important
jobs they too must take essential ground school
instruction the basic knowledge of flying helps
them to stop the many airline ticket offices many
men can be relieved of jobs and radio repair by
trained women workers girls learn to staff radio
stations as technicians writers and announcers
in the increasingly technical field of industrial
and military service colleges everywhere are
designing courses to supply train demanded women
at the University of Texas located in Austin the
state capital petroleum engineering is naturally
considered important the petroleum needs of the
United Nations are studied by students who
will soon be ready for field assignments this
is a pilot plant for converting natural gas to
acetylene which may be a basic requirement for
making synthetic rubber this advanced class
in aeronautics added for the war effort give
students a thorough appreciation of what
makes airplane motors work Latin American
relations are emphasized at Texas this group is
studying our mutual problems in order to promote
better understanding of our southern neighbors
students broadcast in Spanish to Central and
South American countries from the campus radio
station decoding and censorship agencies need
people versed in the languages of our enemies
this group is learning Japanese the science of
nutrition is given special attention by the Home
Economics Department here an advanced class is
doing research work on the vitamin content of
ordinary foodstuffs in an attempt to improve
diets at home special classes like this drafting
group have been added to train women for jobs in
the war plants in this university nursery class
trains girls to relieve mothers for work at the
industrial front at Cornell University in
New York State the peaceful appearance of
the campus has changed more than a thousand new
uniformed men have been added like Dartmouth Notre
Dame and Harvard for example Cornell is being
used by the Navy to Train recently commissioned
civilians besides drill routine they must learn
naval regulations organization and discipline
Bentsen studied the operation
and maintenance of diesel motors
for engineered duty on patrol boats the
Cornell ROTC unit learned how to use gun
fire control instruments out of established
the communication centers at battle funds
the operation of portable equipment so important
in fast-moving troop anubis rolling stock must
be kept and repaired in these cadets practice
and army trucks the artillery unit drills for
speed and precision learning how to make the
instruments of war is a requirement of the
engineering department here high school
teachers learn to make gliders to train
students of the New York schools in the art of
flying many College nutrition departments are
contributing materially to solve the problem
of butter foods at lower cost these Cornell
students are working on methods to condense
high vitamin foods for our troops knowing the
languages of our allies hastens understanding
experts on Latin America the Far East and the
British Commonwealth meet in the Cornell
workshop with selected high school teachers
throughout the country to determine methods of
spreading understanding of the United Nations
colleges are adding new courses for war
training and are putting new emphasis on old
ones for example here at Tulane University
in New Orleans classes in meteorology and
celestial navigation now teach students how
a thousand armors are charted on long raids
to their objectives and safely home again
aiming for duty with the Armed Forces men
in physics classes study the complex problems
of aviation Tulane's Green Wave flying unit
this group will train together in the Navy's
advanced flying forces the naval ROTC learns
how to train a gun on the enemy as part of a
study of tactics and science of naval warfare
army doctors study diseases of the tropics in
two lanes famed medical school these officers
will take care of our soldiers at the tropical
bunks Hampton Institute of Virginia offers many
courses to train men and women for our war
program trained nurses are an urgent demand
this group studies water pollution and methods
of discovering it the chemistry department is
doing much research in the development of new
war materials that will be more effective than
any now known and the well-equipped machine shops
students are turning out war materials while they
learn workers from nearby shipyard as well as
students take advantage of one of the many step
up courses sailors as well as soldiers are
sent to Hampton to take specialized courses
Dartmouth College at Tolliver New Hampshire
started as a school to teach Indians the
principles for which we are now fighting one of
the special war forces added to the curriculum
often meets in the steps of old Dartmouth all this
class prepares men for the military service they
will soon enter this course is designed to
acquaint students with the causes of today's
world problems and why we will continue to
fight for democratic principles one of the
greatest contributions of the liberal arts
colleges is the study of post-war problems
experts and International Affairs guide scientific
thinking to the problems that will arise after
peace is declared the need of help at nearby New
England farms is met by students who volunteer for
part-time work while they gain physical fitness
they help to meet the shortage of manpower
the University of North Carolina at Chapel
Hill in this war of alert trained persons
students are learning the facts about the
world in which we live in the belief that
too little is known about our great ally
Brazil these Portuguese speaking scholars
meet to discuss mutual problems world regional
planning teaches that the way to make a nation
strong in war and in post-war reconstruction is
to strengthen each region and to provide for a
greater unity of national culture and economy
like the universities of Georgia Iowa and st.
Mary's North Carolina houses the naval pre-flight
training school these hand-picked officers are
former coaches and they're out to make naval
cadets that toughest fliers in the world new
arrivals are immediately given long hours of
drill and in a few days are marching like that one
one of the most popular parts of the training
program is the engineers unit physical fitness
of all kinds is started early in the morning and
each student would compete in every event boxing
teaches alertness and ohan combat learning how
to fight effectively at close quarters track meet
strengthen leg muscles hard knocks a football
softens bodies swimming develops endurance this
program gives cadets confidence to meet any
emergency auto jump from a ship at sea how to
swim to safety under burning oil colleges all
over the nation now emphasize physical fitness
here at Harvard students know the answer to our
cues ations that we are soft they are determined
to prepare for their jobs in all ways the fatigue
laboratory studies reactions to physical exertion
and extreme conditions under which human beings
may work it is at present almost entirely devoted
to problems connected with the army and air
forces the center of Chinese and Japanese
studies is the Harvard yenching library where
our oriental relations get special attention
the famous Harvard Yard is now used by the
naval officers for early morning assembly
quartermaster cadets taking the advanced Business
Administration course was stationed at Harvard for
16 months in their studies they've learned how
to run on many army camps and to supervise camp
kitchens to see that our soldiers get the best
of cooked foods in the Far West the University
of California hundreds of universities now have a
West Point and Annapolis like appearance as they
supplement the training of our great military
academies California has one of the largest and
best-equipped of the naval ROTC units College
laboratories are contributing new information
and materials vital to the war effort at this
California pilot plant meat fruit and other
foods are successfully dehydrated to one-fifth
their former size this allows one ship to carry
the load of many to our lives and troops abroad
classes and mechanical designing prepare many
girls to take jobs in nearby aviation plants
and shipyards college hospitals give training
to girls who will help meet the demand for nurses
at the fighting fronts classroom training in all
phases of military theory and practice is given
by experienced army officers to ROTC students
who are anxious to learn the latest methods
of warfare they learn to identify landmarks
and relief maps built to scale and to quickly
compute firing distances the Coast artillery
Department uses complete range finding and
firing equipment cadets learn how to handle
rifles and pistols ottawa symbol machine guns
how to load 75 millimeter guns and the waffle
rate heavy Coast artillery these cadets will
be fully trained when they are called to duty
Texas Aggies have gone all out
for war $6,000 TC cadets train
the year round for all branches
of the army the chemical warfare
unit and gas mask drill practices under
possible wartime conditions in the gas
chamber cadets now learn all fundamentals
of fighting from veterans of many battles
conversion to ward is being made
complete these are our college men today
Harden's body's technically skills fully
trained graduating into a world of war